et tout de suite c'est l'invité de Paris
direct
[Musique]
et nous recevons ce matin Vincent
jarrousseau bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes photographier
documentariste votre livre les femmes du
lien aux éditions Les Arènes qui est ici
vient de sortir nous y découvrons huit
femmes lui les femmes que vous avez
suivies presque pendant deux ans avant
et pendant la pandémie de covid 19 des
femmes dont les métiers pourtant
essentiels sont peu connus peut reconnus
voire même plutôt
ignorer notamment par les pouvoirs
publics et pourtant ces femmes sont des
héroïnes du quotidien est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer tout d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une femme du lien
c'est une expression effectivement
extrêmement large mais déjà ça concerne
environ 3 millions de femmes en France
c'est à dire une actif sur quatre ce
sont des métiers tout simplement où on
prend soin des autres on prend soin de
personne plutôt en situation de
vulnérabilité soit à cause de l'âge du
grand âge ou dans le cas de très jeunes
enfants dans le cas du handicap et
évidemment de la maladie et ce sont des
métiers qui tentent aujourd'hui à se
développer de plus en plus les besoins
on le sait dans les décennies qui
viennent vont croître énormément or la
problématique de ce métier comme vous le
disiez au début c'est des besoins mais
en même temps il y a aussi une
invisibilité et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une grande
difficulté comme dans d'autres secteur
vous me direz à recruter du personnel
mais y compris à assurer des services de
base on l'a vu
attirer les jeunes parce que ce sont des
métiers certes qui apportent beaucoup de
reconnaissance dans la mesure où on a un
sentiment d'utilité sociale extrêmement
fort c'est ce que j'ai remarqué avec
comme ça mais elle l'exprime très très
fortement dans le livre elles savent
pourquoi elles sont là elles savent
pourquoi elles font ce métier mais le
problème c'est que la société les
reconnaît pas nécessairement dans leur
dans la fonction essentielle qu'elles
accomplissent d'ailleurs on voit par
exemple quand même que les mentalités
commencent un petit peu à changer
puisque la fille de Séverine que l'on
découvre dans ce livre qui est
auxiliaire de vie sociale a fini par
elle aussi choisir le même métier que sa
mère elle le dit elle-même elle a
pourtant longtemps considéré un ce
métier comme un sous-métier puis
finalement elle a fait un stage et puis
elle s'est rendu compte et ben en fait
que c'était un super métier et elle a
commencé à dire à sa mère mais en fait
voilà comment j'ai pu dire finalement
que que c'était un sous métier
c'est ce qu'on disait finalement c'est
difficile de convaincre les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui que ce ne sont pas des
sous-métiers bien au contraire oui c'est
vrai que c'est un travail de conviction
si on prend le cas des auxiliaires de
vie sociale des aides à domicile qu'on
appelait par le passé des aides
ménagères on les a bien plus c'est
beaucoup plus que ça on les a souvent
afficher entre guillemets même si c'est
pas pêche géographique les femmes de
ménage or elles font elles assurent des
tâches de soins de toilettes notamment
pour les pour les personnes âgées elles
permettent à des personnes âgées de
rester à domicile c'est une des grandes
aspirations d'ailleurs dans le monde
occidental c'est une nouveauté où les
personnes âgées souhaitent vieillir le
plus longtemps possible chez elle et
donc ceux-ci demande évidemment beaucoup
plus d'interventions à domicile avec
toute une chaîne d'intervention il y a
le métier d'auxiliaire de vie sociale
mais on voit aussi le développement des
infirmières libérales en domicile qui
est des ergothérapeutes décidaient donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a des besoins de plus
en plus accrus dans ce domaine et puis
elle crée ce fameux lien ces femmes du
lien ce lien pour des personnes qui sont
souvent isolées qui n'ont plus forcément
de famille ou des familles qui sont loin
justement elles apportent c'est un peu
un peu de chaleur on va dire un peu de
chaleur humaine un peu de convivialité
assez personne qui n'ont plus rien ça il
faut aussi c'est important de le mettre
en avant et on le voit d'ailleurs
notamment avec Florenza aussi qui est
dans occupe Marie Basile exactement moi
pour écrire ce livre j'ai souhaité
travailler sur deux territoires bien
distincts un territoire rural dans le
nord de la France et en région
parisienne en milieu rural c'est assez
particulier parce que les femmes du lien
ont vraiment une centralité sociale ce
sont elles qui sont présentes dans les
campagnes se sont telles qui tiennent
les campagnes de par leur profession
parce qu'il y a à la fois beaucoup de
personnes âgées il y a des enfants aussi
et si elles ont une place centrale au
niveau de leur métier elles l'ont aussi
au plan social dans la société locale
c'est-à-dire ce sont elles qui tiennent
les familles qui sont présentes auprès
de leurs enfants ou leurs propres
grands-parents
et c'est vrai qu'en ville c'est un peu
différencie on prend par exemple le cas
de Florenza Marie Basile qui est aussi
auxiliaire de vie la visite tous les
jours passés énormément de temps c'est
une personne en situation de grande
dépendance
et les enfants sont pas là et souvent
ces femmes qui interviennent au domicile
des personnes âgées sont les seules
personnes
les seuls représentantes du monde
extérieur finalement que ces personnes
âgées peuvent voir
pendant la crise du covid les Français
applaudissent chaque soir le corps
médical Séverine dit les gens qui
applaudissent ce n'est pas pour nous je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il pense à nous on en
revient à ce manque de reconnaissance de
considération qui est très pesant pour
ces professions ces femmes en souffrent
elles se sentent impuissantes il y a eu
un petit espoir quand même avec la loi
sur le grand âge qui était censé
reconnaître les aides du grand âge
justement pourquoi ça a été abandonné
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire du coup
aujourd'hui oui c'est un peu le drame de
ce secteur on l'a vu avant-hier il y a
eu une journée de mobilisation des
métiers de l'humain à l'appel de grande
fédération
professionnelle dans ce secteur personne
n'en a parlé ou ça a été très peu très
peu évoqué or on parle de sujets
extrêmement importants de sujets
d'avenir sur la prise en charge des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
et c'est vrai que on a beaucoup parlé de
l'hôpital pendant le covid on a vu que
ces professions du médico-social je
pense aussi aux éducateurs aux
travailleurs sociaux qui joue un rôle
extrêmement important de réparation
ont été complètement mis de côté pendant
le Ségur il y a une prise en
considération qui commence timidement à
avancer on l'a vu avec cette certaine
mesure concernant les aides à domicile
mais aujourd'hui il faut le dire la
prime commune Macron bon c'est pas le
1000 euros mais bon il y en a plein qui
en ont pas bénéfice c'est tout à fait
ponctuelle il faut bien voir que par
exemple une année à domicile doit
attendre 15 ans pour attendre
prétendre un SMIC mensuel c'est
absolument inadmissible aujourd'hui vous
avez des services d'aide à domicile qui
sont dans une situation je pèse mes mots
catastrophiques c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui vous avez des directeurs de
services d'aide à domicile qui sont
obligés de refuser à des familles des
prises en charge de leurs parents très
âgés en situation de dépendance on en
est là aujourd'hui aussi bien à Paris
que dans les campagnes donc
véritablement il y a un problème ce
livre il est là je dirais pour montrer
les tréfonds de ces métiers de montrer
aussi
l'intelligence aussi de ces femmes se
sont vraiment des métiers qui supposent
beaucoup d'intelligence affectives
malheureusement le valorise pas
suffisamment d'ailleurs toutes disent
qu'elles manque beaucoup de temps avec
leur patients et qu'elles aimeraient on
le ressent dans votre livre et qu'elles
aimeraient vraiment passer plus de temps
mais est-ce que ce serait vraiment
possible vous dites c'est un peu la
course elles sont toujours obligées
d'aller d'une maison à une autre et de
se dépêcher pour faire leurs heures il y
a pas de fatalité vous avez des
fonctionnements différents selon les
services d'aide à domicile par exemple
si on prend le cas de Marie Basile Marie
Vasile dans son organisation qui est la
sienne là où elle travaille à la
possibilité de d'assurer d'évacuation
plus longue chez les personnes âgées
alors on est à Paris il y a aussi plus
de pouvoir d'achat
et il y a pas de fatalité à ce que les
auxiliaires de vie passent seulement une
demi-heure pour assurer une toilette un
habillement et la préparation d'un repas
et le ménage chez une personne âgée
parce que c'est le drame c'est que
souvent ces personnes sont aussi là et
ça c'est pas on peut pas comptabiliser
la prise en charge affective d'une
certaine manière parce que c'est pas
quantifiable or dans ces métiers comme
dans le médical
tout est quantifié d'une certaine
manière c'est un peu la ce qu'on appelle
la prise en charge à l'acte un dernier
mot sur sur la façon dont vous avez
choisi d'illustrer ce livre on le voit
bien leur il y a des il y a des dessins
les dessins sous la forme d'une BD je
pense qu'on va aussi le voir à l'antenne
voilà on le voit ici ce sont des dessins
et puis donc on comprend que tout ça
c'est la vie passée et puis après il y a
vos photos qui représentent la vie
actuelle comment vous est venu justement
cette idée de de plutôt privilégier le
côté BD des saints pour le passé et vos
photos pour pour la vie actuelle
la forme du roman photo mais c'est du
documentaire tout est vrai c'est que
dans les bulles ce sont des paroles qui
sont enregistrées retranscrites et
validés par les les protagonistes et
l'idée de la BD alors ce sont les
dessins de thieriches avant l'idée de la
BD c'était effectivement pour raconter
ce passé parce que le passé de ces
femmes est très évocateur il permet de
comprendre aussi pourquoi on a des
professions aussi genré avec 90% de de
femmes plus de 90% de femmes parce que
souvent il y a une assignation à
l'enfance
otage de mystique donc ça c'est la BD
permet de comprendre et c'est vrai
qu'après on glisse sur le présent d'où
la photographie il y a vraiment une
forme qui peut parfois rebuter certaines
personnes ça n'a rien à voir avec les
romans photos à l'eau de rose
c'est pas le professeur showroom non
plus on est vraiment dans quelque chose
qui est immersif pour le lecteur
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'identifie
extrêmement fortement à toutes ces
femmes et une émotion qui est transmise
enfin moi j'ai été émue plusieurs fois
par certaines images et par certaines
choses qui sont dites de façon très
simple dans cette petite bulle mais en
fait ça dit tout il y a un système de
double lecture en fait entre les paroles
de ces femmes qui sont retranscrites et
il y a beaucoup de choses qui passent
aussi par l'image phénomène
d'identification et voilà c'est une
forme narrative un peu nouvelle mais qui
moi intéressante merci beaucoup Vincent
jarroso d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle le titre de votre livre les
femmes du lien et je le conseille merci
beaucoup restez avec nous dans un
instant on retrouve Sandrine Gomez pour
un nouveau journal là tout de suite
[Musique]